there is this big climate conference
right now and you guys get it you get
the hypocrisy with these people they fly
in their private jets trust me these
people don't give a f
poop about the environment what they
like is power
they as they slowly shift us out of
covid the next thing that they will try
to lock us down for
is the environment and they'll tell you
not to drive your car so much while they
fly in private jets and they'll tell you
to eat bugs while they eat wagyu steak
in elysium etc etc well two-term
president barack obama he showed up to
this thing and he gave a little talk and
if uh if you want to watch the
definition of hypocrisy take a look
with a higher per capita carbon
footprint does have to do more than
a country like mali or bangladesh
it's also why we need to make sure the
people most affected by the transition
to clean energy aren't the ones bearing
most of the cost
they don't have any margin for error
i can afford to give up a lot
of my current lifestyle to benefit the
planet because i'll still have a lot
left over a lot of folks don't have that
cushion
so that means that any climate plan
worth of salt has to take
these inequities into account whether
it's through subsidies
to poor people to ease the transition to
clean energy whether it's technology
transfers that help poor countries meet
their development goals by leapfrogging
dirty fuels we have to pay attention
to those
embedded inequities
and the politics that surrounds that
and that's not easy
do you guys see how this stuff is just
all connected like this is what build
back better is this is what the sort of
globalist
order is all about we create crises and
then we lecture you you the people who
will have to get used to less but we
certainly will not and the reason i said
that this is
an exercise in hypocrisy basically
listening to him is he said that he can
afford to give up a lot
he can afford to give up a lot well i
was thinking well what has barack obama
given up i think we've got an image
we've got an image that's barack obama's
new house that's an
11.75 million dollar house right by the
water it's very very close to the water
i hope it's on stilts that's in martha's
vineyard massachusetts where it's
surrounded by the elite and the rich and
all of the people who have all of the
stuff that you do not if i'm not
mistaken barack obama also has a house
in palm springs which is the middle of
the desert
um here in you know outside of los
angeles where there's nothing there and
they've had to pump tons and tons of
water there to just make sure that the
rich people can have their nice pools
and everything else i'm not against rich
people number one i'm not against rich
people having nice things i'm not
against pools i'm not against mansions
you can have all of those things but try
not to be such a hypocrite about it if
barack obama really feared that the
water was rising at such an alarming
rate that we're going to have to figure
out how to help other countries uh
leapfrog their way so that they don't
have to deal with dirty energy like we
did because we're very guilty and white
supremacist blah blah blah
if he really believed any of this was
true he would not can we get that house
again look at that how many rooms is
that thing that is a lot of rooms in
that thing they got rooms i guarantee
you he's got a gym i guarantee he's got
a sauna and a steam room and again i
don't begrudge him any of these things i
do wonder how he got millions and
millions of dollars i mean i know
netflix gave him a ton of money to
promote propaganda on netflix but like
would you be living right by the water
you know we just came back from miami
and in miami you've got all of these
literally these 30 40 50 70 million
dollar houses all on the water
right and they're telling us the sea
level's rising get why are all the rich
people still moving to the water are
they stupid
or
could it possibly be
that all of this is really about control
and they're trying to usher in a whole
bunch of polities that policies that
will enshrine that they always kind of
stay in power and you eat bugs
bug mush with a little salt it's
delicious
foreign